[Musique]
le jour se lève à peine
ce spectacle étrange entrevue par la
portière d'un train qui vient de
traverser la nuit et rentrer dans paris
le 5 à 7 du matin après les fêtards
avant les travailleurs ont nettoyé la
ville de fond en comble
c'était des femmes beaucoup de femmes
j'ai voulu en savoir davantage
[Musique]
j'avais déjà fait des ménages parce que
c'est ce que les ménages le matin oh oui
on sait faire tous les deux dans les
bureaux où il joue et des ménages on
sait faire discret bon eh bien c'est
bien je vais voir ce que je peux vous
donner pas très loin quoi
voyez vous pour y faire vous pourriez à
la porte d'auteuil
moi ce que vous aurez tous les deux dans
même chantier oui ce serait bien ce
serait mieux pour d'emprunt ce que comme
ça c'est assez loin aussi c'est ça oui
j'ai fouillé pour 6 heures s'il faut
prendre le premier métro oui je sais pas
si vous pourriez gagner parce qu'il ya
un changement vous n'êtes pas loin de
ressentir on est on est on est il venu
cinq fois et nous avons la part du on a
la bouche de métro l'appareil comment
pouvait on lire en violences
info oui on vit ce qu'on a vu un très
grand naturellement je jette au chantier
oui mais il faut pas de femmes là on a
comme une heure tout de suite là vous
avez trois heures trois heures 6 heures
à 9 heures oui c'est peut-être vous
pourrez continuer oui continuez c5 dans
la journée en faire on verra si vous
savez bien vous orienter dans le travail
vendredi
on se débrouille bon c'est trois francs
de l'heure oui sinon je prends de
l'heure pour le lavage oui mais là
vraiment
j'ai eu la rage qu'on fait c'est pas
j'ai pas tellement bien que non mais
vous savez faire des bureaux dans le
matin
vous avez été au 86 rue marcadet c'est à
dire vers montmartre
voilà en plein vous avez jusqu où
jusqu'à avenue matignon
c'est à dire une chance disent les
champs-elysées l'euro plein c'est à dire
environ 4 km ok je vous avais 76 bec
message et une vie régulière 1 que ce
soit chez couché de bonne heure demande
pas de mort est la couleur
6h30
depuis combien de temps vous faites ce
chemin ça va faire huit ans et en pleine
neige l'hiver en pleine neige à pied
et quand il pleut pareil
ça fait combien de temps vous avez perdu
votre mari c'est un chat depuis ce
moment-là vous faites le ménage mais je
travaille encore en atelier le début que
j'ai perdu mon mari
et puis journaliste ancien licencié ce
parlement où on voulait gagner un autre
poste que j'ai pas voulu faire j'ai dit
j'ai compris je m'en vais et comme vous
faites alors que les ménages
maintenant j'ai et massants prendre
leurs avants n'avaient 265 en fait deux
heures tous les matins le gérer demi ça
vous faites comme moi par mois à peu
près contre 1000 kits mis 38 depuis
presque vingt mille de pension à vie car
le regarde et vous passez des copies qui
vous savez
j'exerce je peux le dire j'ai peur
et si vous l'invitez certains en voir là
la banque j'évite le coin de l'art du
café qui est le coin là j'ai vu deux
trois vagues est relatif alors vous
savez j'ai vie qui passe et se passe par
ici
quels sont tes arrières à je ne sais pas
qui se battait avec une guérison l'aller
les tables dehors vous avez un type
ulrich eké facteurs alors moi ça ne
m'avait pas plus
alors après je pensais par ici supporter
were là et je traverse et en face après
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci
à l'arrivée je te remercie bas manhattan
où m tout ça c'est long mais parce que
de sarcelles à farinia pas de d'autobus
mars à partir de 5h30 et savoirs savoir
pour leur échapper sa fête du chien la
chapelle ou alors la pause la ville est
le maintien le choix de foi du matin
allez voir
ok
cette fois et michael bay
alors qu'hier c'est maurice 3
et
[Musique]
comment sérail à quelle heure jusqu'à 9
heures et après ce jeûne
certains soirs de 18h ça fait à peu près
[Musique]
où vous êtes une femme de ménage
professionnels s'en tenir là c'est
l'essentiel de votre activité
oui et vous comment se fait-il que vous
vous exercer ce métier là ça parce que
c'est un métier où je suis libre et moi
j'aime bien ma liberté rien et on
apprend la personne derrière le voyons
on fait notre travail on sait ce qu'on a
à faire
le plus fou dit moi c'est la grande
liberté qui me voilà j'aurais pu faire
autre chose en fait
[Musique]
e
dans l'est
madame guzzo fait donc douze heures de
ménage six heures pour le compte d'une
entreprise dans un magasin puis dans un
théâtre
ensuite six heures chez des particuliers
à part il existe une centaine
d'entreprises de nettoyage en tout genre
entretien journalier ménages de bureaux
et administrations magasin usine
dépoussiérage lessivage encaustique âge
aspirations etc
les matinales de paris sont donc en
réalité des ouvrières nettoyeuses et pas
des femmes de ménage
[Musique]
oui
sasha 7 ans
savait pas en 4h30 16h45 comme
d'habitude - à la porte et a chanté ça
vous fait combien de temps avec ses amis
et vous ne travaillez qui signent pas
vous ne croyez pas dans d'autres
endroits
je suis moi mais quel âge vous avez les
71 ans
et depuis c'est un oui et auparavant
rallié j'ai toujours travaillé le
faisait auparavant
bah j'ai cru que je suis à paris ça fait
un nom depuis sa tante et là je fais
toujours des ménages se joue est
toujours des cafés macha grenon je
faisais des bureaux
j'avais chez des particuliers mon
préféré dans le café parce que non mes
chefs n'ont mis là parce que je
travaille pour une entreprise
adacore notre presqu'île où il
s'épanouit
mais c'est matt reprise molle jeux 183
c'est pas beau 283 froid
le matin vous rencontré beaucoup de
femmes de ménage qui est nice à partir
du métro
beaucoup beaucoup combien me fait jouer
le nombre n'est pas bien définies ça
dépend leur les moyens financiers soir
même
pourquoi parce que y'a voyait beaucoup
de gens qui ne viennent pas pour
implication dans ce genre de travail là
à l'époque de la paye c'est meilleur
nathalie lahaie datant de se voir après
ce genre de clientèle vous avez le matin
ouvrière essentiellement ouvrière les
fans de voyage les ouvriers de chez
citroën rend l'eau et les cent des
ménages aussi alexis ballesta env
essentiellement les femmes de ménage qui
partent vers les bureaux les usines le
métro à 5h30 suis arrivé tard il afin de
leur faire part non pas une seconde à
perdre parce que c'est chronométrés j'ai
toujours lui-même tous là c'est toujours
la même depuis les années que je suis
vous les connaissez presque toutes en
janvier reconnaît comme elle arrive au
pas je reconnais c'est ce matin que mal
un peu paris jour ces mêmes hausses de
tarifs je me retourne même pas seulement
le pays à la semaine on se retourne même
pas
on n'a pas prêt à faire le matin non
parce qu'il ya vous femmes je sais
qu'ils arrivent pour ma femme s'était
sécurité parce que disait sécurité comme
ça c'est si c'est quelque chose je le
connaisse il sait que je ne connais pas
immédiatement elle prend des précautions
nécessaires
aboul vecteur 95 vous avez tous parlent
pas et tous les matins ou bien vous avez
la main quel âge avez vous
j'ai sur 73 vous a fait longtemps vous
travaillez lagarce 12 ans de son passing
est auparavant passé la soirée qu'il
était là tout le temps à l'époque je
travaillais
[Applaudissements]
quand vous jouez dans le métro aussi
vous rencontrez toujours aux mêmes
camarades
oui on se connaît tout ou presque y en
ad'autres tous vous rencontrer aussi
dans le métro c'est ça ici sur lequel il
y en a une
vous avez une karine desmoulin et puis
dans le métro vous rencontrez d'autres
levé vous voit elle travaille également
à la gare saint lazare et non non vous
nous expliquer que ce que vous faites
vous la gare saint lazare
j'ai la boite piles et puis le ballet je
balaie le dans la salle des pas perdus
et beaucoup de monde
ah oui on sait pas ce qui manque ça vous
fait peur un peu non oui on est on y est
habitués vous faire attention tout de
même il faut faire attention
j'ai déjà été bousculé le calme et
propre n'ait été bousculée ça s'est mal
passé mais je parle bien au mois de
juillet
c'est un voyageur qui n'avait de série b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nan paris environ vingt mille femmes
sont employées chaque jour par les
entreprises de nettoyage
elles ont les mêmes avantages sociaux
que les autres travailleurs sécurité
sociale retraites et congés payés au
delà d'un très petit nombre d'heures de
travail par exemple trois heures pour un
enfant les mères de familles perdent
leurs droits à l'allocation de salaire
unique ce qui limite le recrutement
[Musique]
ça c'est mon et cage tout ça ça va quand
même de vos pensées et sutton à 14
j'aime voir gfk bâton c'est réparable 60
ans est en fait arrivé j'avais l'europe
oui c'est ça alors on va peut-être vu la
demande s'ils vont pas te salit tout ça
je veux dire à tous que je dessine en
mai
[Musique]
de leur dommage
bonjour
bon ça va toutes les heures autour de
nous ce matin oui la boj monde et pour
la wii
madame
encore pensé à moi je pense un peu un
patou puis à rien moi je pense quand je
travaille moi vous savez je pense qu'un
chiffre est si inquiet si j'avais
l'argent je frissonne
je pense je fais tout le temps de calcul
vous savez je pratique toujours des
châteaux quelquefois il sait que le
remarquer mais en fait c'est moi c'est
une manie chez moi qu'est ce que vous
voulez je passe toujours alors quelques
formes mboso
j'entends fille dans mes pensées
forme d'un tiers des nouvelles banques
l'aimé toujours de vin ou ne veulent pas
y aller parce que eh bien si on me voit
mais qui voulez vous dis moi oui mais si
j'ai choisi de me voir lesquels voient
que je fais le ménage de quoi je vais
avoir l'air déshonneur voilà pour elle
c'est un déshonneur faire des ménages
pourquoi il ya ces considérations là je
ne sais pas chez fram de ménage c'est
pas joli or mon dieu femme de ménage
alors heureux voilà voilà ce qu'elle
dise alors elle préfère manger un
croissant 20 journées et un temps deux
autres biens n'est pas moi enfin son et
est responsable parce que moi quand je
suis à table il ya de quoi manger sur la
tapisserie préfère vous le dire
de quoi être bousculé ans corpulent non
seulement
par contre tout à l'heure ça va venir
killer 7 heures et demie entre cette
traînée jusqu'à nevers magny sera
temporaire
c'est dangereux à ce moment là on est
ancien
quand vous avez fini de une fois la
salle des pas perdus vont recommencer à
comment vous faites oui de lecture j'ai
pris de la bo du fait et je vais
retourner sur l'autre côté et après et
je recommence la même la même chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes français de l'espagnol et
aliens et hagen
les enfants
des moquettes chez vous
le ponant vous travaillez spending non
je ne pense pas à quoi vous pensez furie
je pars compris pensée etc ou billet
vert remontait le moral par votre
jeunesse ma jeunesse série du même temps
pas vous avez des gens qui mangent que
vous êtes le papier par terre les
cigarettes qui veut jeter les bouteilles
les il ya des verts passé vous avez les
traces de la légende qui qui ont peur
des portes par exemple instinctivement
et vous mettre les mains sur vous avez
les enfants des doigts plein de bonbons
plein de chocolat salle vous avez des
groupes qui sont pas mieux qu'ils
s'amusent à griffonner sur la peinture
sur les formica alors c'est obligé
d'être fait que 12 autres avaient donc
parce que la ville est trop dire
j'arriverai pas avec le salaire des gens
comme ça j arrive difficile en comme
level 2 me c'est à 290,8 jusqu'où pas
moi sur renault puis dans le budget de
l'idole comment vous faites comme moi je
suis allée 55 à peu près 50 7
c'était que tous les deux vous deviez
pas 150 mille francs à 20 points et vous
c'est un travail de combien d'heures par
ennuis cette saison 11 heures c'est un 6
heures du matin vous avez essayé de
travail fatigant c'est à dire j'aurais
pu travailler dur mais ça m'intéresse
pas à cause des enfants
il faudrait que l'état n'a gardé ou bien
les horreurs ne conviendrait pas pour
les envoyer en place pratique quand il
sortirait de l'école ça n'arrangerait
pas si vous aviez à choisir vos
préférable d'être ouvrière femme de
ménage bien pendant le magal rien dit ou
rester chez moi
[Applaudissements]
ce matin j'ai cassé le troisième un pied
cassé le roi des mythes avec les 73 76
alors au troisième contrairement à hier
en fait là où aujourd'hui ça s'est
cassée par un mytho
[Applaudissements]
voyez-vous guirec ses marques et mary
blair et du crayon vous fassiez bien
attention la vacation ce quoi exactement
dans les weppes / dollar et des trayons
rapport d'une fauteuil
votre teint qui soit comme ça et il n'a
pas à 60 cm de la table juste ce sont
ces messieurs et à les bouger
windham
oui c'est ça vous la connaissez on ne
connaît pas vous l'avez
et puis faut rien de fait pour remettre
comme ça faut pas qu'elles viennent par
exemple
bah
et vous gagneriez d'avantagés
particuliers
oui mais il faut avoir été habitués ce
pas été habitués l'affiché particulier
je me sens gêné parce que j'ai beaucoup
de complexes avec ces gens le bourgeois
oui évidemment j'aurais intérêt parce
que d'ailleurs je payer beaucoup plus
cher ça s'enflamme leur payer mais ce
qui me paralyse c'est quand elles
viennent nous parler ces gens là je sens
leur instruction générale hier tout ça
ça m'intimide oui et vous étiez ouvrière
auparavant oui j'ai travaillé en usine
vous avez travaillé mon temps dit un oui
j'ai travaillé à ces montants ainsi
expliqué mme marois quoi vous n'êtes pas
respect parce que
bon normalement rentrer en même temps on
se dispute et forcément il y avait la
fatigue de toute la journée on se
disputait fréquemment et ailleurs ça
n'allait pas alors on a trouvé la
solution fallait que je travaille
habitants j'étais moins fatigué je me
suis rendu compte que tout allait mieux
tu auras est pour ça c'est tout le
travail de travail est moins fatiguant
par une femme de ménage
c'est à dire que je refais pas j'en fais
- oui de maya moins d'heures alors ça me
permet de faire la cuisine et de
préparer il n'a pas à courir lui d'aller
chercher les oeufs ou bifteck voyez
chacun et puis moi aller courir derrière
l'autre côté chercher le linge qu'il
portait à la blanchisserie ou ou des
trucs comme ça comme ça tout est lui
lave n'a plus besoin de rien faire à ce
moment là puis alors il est moins
fatigué aussi puis moi aussi lorsque
vous parlez avec les employés des
magasins mais c'est difficile quand même
de toute façon parce que honnêtement
c'est une femme de ménage et puis
une vendeuse s'est déjà fait la même
chose quand on est ensemble en sang
évidemment je suis pas dire qu'elles
sont désagréables parce qu'ils sont très
aimables et je vous dise bonjour
enfin je crois que ça s'arrête là voyez
est quelque chose de différent
hier samedi on sent qu'il ya quelque
chose vous savez où c'en est tenace ça
s'explique par le sens du mépris ou pas
du mépris mais la différence surtout
beaucoup d'indifférence générale de
livres
oui mais pas seulement les embrouilles
et demandé un jour oui c'est partout
dans les bureaux c'est exactement la
même chose c'est sûr de déconsidération
oui c'est ça comme on l'a toujours
écrasé du rsa femme de ménage alors ça
reste je trouve ça bizarre c'est pas
arrivé 20e siècle de bar salon devrait
être on dit que les gens ont évolué et
moi je trouve pas tellement c'est vrai
ils font
[Musique]
et
chez eux pour aller autre part tout à
l'heure fatima qui remettra les chefs un
petit peu plus loin oui ma bien ta on
ira au foyer des musiciens je regarde ce
que fait tomber la poussière et miss
marguerite et pendant que je suis à 100
des bons choix tout à fait drôlement
temps plein sur moi
ils ont l'habitude de mettre à niveau la
partie fut alors ça m'ennuie cette
histoire commence à fait rien et
j'attends c'est pas gentil petit fellini
les corps de l'opéra sont pas là des x
men to me
[Rires]
[Musique]
sa tenue
ça
ouais
ce
défenseurs mais taylor ça dans la tête
dénoncent les deux chaînes regardées
qu'est ce que ça leur coûte sont là des
places en la déplaçant que la retourne
pour la retirer
on va leur mettre comme ça tu sais tout
[Musique]
by savais pas si je suis au casier la
rencontre on augmente un peu tous les
jours de la semaine parce que tout soit
fini
[Musique]
banier ou telle auto à vis à vis au nom
de la vérité
[Musique]
une barre haute et qui hélas sans
panache problème ces fatwas vous n'avez
[Applaudissements]
pu aussi mais bien nos points de
résister mais où
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les matinales ont terminé les autres
arrivent la journée commence
[Musique]
de l'autre la fia gt lt lt nous ruiner